kurz hat vor allem auch von der
ideologie gewarnt die mit einigen dieser
menschen mit kommen würde nach
deutschland nach österreich auch daher
ein
ich möchte genau diese kranke ideologie
nicht nach europa importieren und ich
sage ihnen was herum zwei mal wenn ich
mir anschaue welche herausforderungen
wir mittlerweile mit menschen haben dem
jahr 2015 und folgende gekommen sind
dann kann ich ihnen nur sagen es gibt
gott sei dank viele die sich gut
integrieren
aber wir haben sehr sehr viele menschen
auch in europa die genau dieses
gedankengut nach europa bringen ja
julian er spricht hier von einer kranken
ideologie beide waren oft in diesen
ländern haben gesehen wozu diese kranke
ideologie fähig ist wiewohl tun findest
du es dass sich hier einer hinstellt und
dass man so klar und deutlich sagt ich
glaube dieser satz ich will diese kranke
ideologie nicht in europa er hat europa
gefehlt dieser satz war überfällig denn
nichts anderes ist der islamismus und
wer ihn einmal erlebt hat der weiß das
auch und er weiß auch dass islamisten
nicht wandlungs und integrationsfähig
sind islamisten wollen nur eine einzige
sache wandeln nämlich wie wir leben
nicht wie sie leben und insofern ist das
ein ganz wichtiger satz von sebastian
kurz diese politische realität einmal so
ganz klar zu benennen und zu sagen dass
auch nach allem was wir in den letzten
jahren erlebt haben dass da terrorismus
mit einwandert dass auch das hat
sebastian kurz gesagt habe dass ich ganz
genauso eine neue archaische barbarische
form von brutalität bei
gewaltkriminalität zum beispiel
eingewandert ist ja dass das messer als
normalzustand der problemlösung damit
eingewandert ist
und ich glaube und hoffe dass dieser
satz von sebastian kurz zu einer
weiteren debatte führen wird die ich für
überragend wichtig für unser land halte
wo beginnt eigentlich islamismus muss
ich einen terroristischen anschlag
planen um islamist zu sein oder reicht
es schon wenn ich glaube dass frauen
weniger wert sind als männer
ich persönlich glaube dass islamismus da
beginnt ich persönlich glaube dass die
punkte politische teil des islam
islamismus ist sozusagen die politische
ideologie des islam
und wenn der wenn diese ideologie mit
unserem grundgesetz nicht in
übereinstimmung zu bringen ist dann
beginnt dort für mich der islamismus und
nicht erst bei der anschlagsplanung und
wenn man diese grenze zieht und ich
glaube wir sollten sie ziehen und ich
glaube wir müssen sie ziehen
wenn wir nicht wollen dass sich der
islamismus und diese kranke ideologie in
europa ausbreitet wenn man diese grenze
zieht dann sprechen wir eben darüber
dass man noch restriktiver sein muss bei
der bei der zuwanderung aus muslimischen
ländern weil der islamismus eben
deutlich früher beginnt als wir uns das
immer eingestehen wollen der islamismus
ist kein phänomen der
strafverfolgungsbehörden oder der
geheimdienste es ist kein phänomen des
der anschlagsplanung und des terrorismus
es ist ein weltbild phänomen und wenn
ich der meinung bin dass homosexuelle
weniger wert sind als andere menschen
oder ich sie gar zur strafe vom dach
werfen oder styling möchte oder das auch
nur ansatzweise für legitim halte wenn
ich der meinung bin
herr wie paul und als geschichte aus
afghanistan mitgebracht hat dass frauen
gewisse rollen haben und nur diese
rollen erfüllen dürfen das sieht für die
tür vor die tür dürfen nur um die tiere
zu füttern
zum beispiel wenn ich der meinung bin
das mädchen im freibad eigentlich nichts
zu suchen haben dann bin ich ein
islamist und das sollten wir so ganz
klar aussprechen und wir sollten ganz
klar sagen dass wir damit in diesem land
und auf diesem kontinent einfach rein
gar nichts zu tun haben wollen und
deswegen bin ich persönlich sehr froh
und sehr dankbar dass sebastian kurz
diesen satz einmal ausgesprochen hat und
ich hoffe es wird sich auch in
deutschland endlich die energische
politische debatte anschließen wo
beginnt für uns der islamismus und der
islamismus muss für uns da beginnen und
das wird problematisch wo menschen
unterschiedlich bewertet und beurteilt
werden und das ist leider ein
flächendeckendes phänomen und kein
radikales phänomen in der in der spitze
muslimischer gesellschaften